this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to audit.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like pressing code Joey
and get 10 off delivered right to your
house what's happened you bad
[__] it's August the 3rd the
joint is brought to you by bluetooth
listen confidence could take you so far
in life it can also help in the bedroom
but that's where Bluetooth comes in blue
chew is an online service that delivers
ingredients as Viagra and Cialis
but insurable tablets all at a fraction
of the cost take them any time and be
ready whenever the opportunity arises
let's cut this [__] it's summertime
everybody wants to get their whistle
[__] licked and this is the best time
to do it August
do me a favor I know that you don't have
any Ed issues or anything but you can
all use some confidence you want them to
call back so you got a sling dick heavy
that's why you got to go with
bluetooth.com listen the process is
simple you sign up at Bluetooth you
consult with one of like medical
providers once you're approved you
receive your prescription within days
the best part is it's all online no
doctor's office no driving no Pharmacy
Bluetooth tablets are made in the U.S
survey and shipped in a discreet package
nobody will know if you can help from a
little extra confidence when it's time
to sling dick and get dirty Bluetooth
will [__] help you try Bluetooth for
free what are you talking about Joey I'm
talking about free
by using promo code Joey j-o-e-y you
just pay five dollars for shipping so do
me a favor go to bluetooth.com enter
code Joey for your first month for free
that's it visit bluetooth.com for more
safety information and again I want to
thank Bluetooth for sponsoring The Joint
the joint is also brought to you by
factor factor is a ready to eat meal
delivery service they make it easy to
stay on top of your schedule while
you're still sticking to your goals with
facta a quick lunch or fully prepared
dinner is two minutes away that's it
just heat them up and eat them they're a
lifesaver when you have no free time
fact that also has protein plus
preference which makes it easy to power
up with delicious meals with at least 30
grams of protein Factor offers 30 meals
a week change your order whenever you
want choose from 4 to 18 meals per week
pause or reschedule you'll deliver
anytime the chef created recipes are
tremendous they're restaurant quality
and you're going to love them stop
spending your present times at the store
it's summertime let Factor deliver
ready-made meals right to your door they
offer vegan veggie Protein Plus keto
calories smart options plus cold pressed
juices and tremendous smoothies do me a
favor head over to go dot Factor
75.com
Joey 130 go to dot
factor75.com
joey130 use code
joey130 to get you 130 off six boxes
that's code
joey130 at go dot
factor75.com Joey 130.
Factor the best in the business the
joint is also brought to you by CBD lion
the lion is [__] getting stronger
than ever you gotta try the little
adhesive pads for your shoulders or your
knees
kinesiology tape they got the cream they
got the capsules any way you could take
CBD to help you CBD lion is dead do me a
favor go to cbdline.com read the third
party lab results and I'll tell you what
they got hemp weed that'll [__] help
you more than anything they got gummies
they got Delta eight gummies that'll
[__] knock you out and I'm Gonna Save
You 20 on your first order by using
coach Joey
or church it's that [__] easy go to
Joey go to
cbdlion.com Preston coach Joey joint a
church and get 20 off and you're gonna
be healthy as [__] let's get this party
started it's Wednesday [__] we
got a guest
[Music]
s
check one two welcome to Uncle Joey's
Joy
[Music]
foreign
oh [__] you bad [__] it's
Wednesday the 3rd of August the heat has
landed in [__] New Jersey it's hot
today it was [__] hot yesterday and
tomorrow they're telling you not even to
leave the [__] house I'm getting up
Thursday morning and I'm shooting right
to the pool and I'm doing a sitting
there all [__] day when you see me
next week I'll be brown as I don't know
one of those Cubans without the SPF
anyway it's a great [__] week uh I
got a great show tonight Uncle Vinnie's
I got a show next Wednesday I'm excited
I got to be honest with you guys I'm uh
it's really weird I've been getting into
comedy again like I I ordered uh stand
up comedy the book you know I
it's just really weird like I love the
creating I loved the beginning of doing
stand-up comedy I love after you shoot a
special searching for material like you
know you'll do like 10 shows before a
[__] anything will come to you and
then when it does come you're like good
now I got something to write off and
then you struggle and struggle and keep
writing and keep writing just the whole
thing about stand up I've always loved
guys I don't know nothing about nothing
I mean I don't know anything about
anything Politics the world why the
Russians are fighting I don't give a
[__]
when I got into comedy I studied comedy
inside and out one thing about me is man
I like to get into [__] I'm a geek about
it like I want the nuts and bolts I want
all the exercises I need I I mean this
is why my Jujitsu is working now because
I'm not on the road I'm scattered I'm at
home I'm controlled you know I do breath
work I do a little bit of everything but
nobody really knows how hard I work to
be a comic a decent comic and I still
think I [__] have a ton of holes in
my game after 30 years but I'm going to
tell you something more it takes 20
years to really give yourself
a shed a shot at stand up like I
remember walking in the main room one
night when I first got to the store
and you know I was a bombing machine
then and I didn't know how how long my
career would last at The Comedy Store
and I remember walking into the main
room one night it was like a quiet
ho-hum night like maybe a Thursday maybe
150 people in New Orleans but Mitzi Shaw
was one of the boots
and I saw that she was in that I tried
to get out before she could see me and
she goes fat baby come here and sit next
to me and I sat next to her and I
watched Paul Rodriguez
for about seven minutes and he was guys
he was just destroying
effortlessly
he was just destroying and before I
could say something to her he she looked
at me Mitzi Shore and she goes that's
what 20 years of Comedy is
the time I was doing comedy maybe like
11 years and I was thinking of [__]
quitting already I was like I'm not
going to do this I'd rather be a
criminal
but when she said that to me I'm like
well if that's what I'm going to be in
nine more years
I might as well stick it out from nine
more [__] years right what do I got
to lose I've already put 11 in this
[__] thing and I've got nowhere
what's another nine and
that statement [__] changed my world
when she said that to me because it made
me
like I started looking at sets as
opportunities
like every time you get a set like I
never I never really like I came from a
place in Denver where you had anywhere
from 10 to 14 sets a month like the
highest amount the sets I did and all
those years in Boulder was 16. and
that's if I went to all the open mices
the Denver Comedy Works I got like two
guest spots and I just did all the rooms
around town
so I understood that a set at from
in a small Market that you had to make
the most of your sets you know when you
could do 20 sets in a week you don't
give a [__] about them but when all you
got is five sets a week you [__]
start working a little harder on them
and you start going you know what they
have to work I have to try this on this
uh I would do sets and not curse I tried
everything guys I tried everything for
as long as I if that's an exercise and
stand-up comedy I [__] did it and it
paid off
and the most important thing about
stand-up comedy is Taking Chances yes
you have to write but you also have to
love Taking Chances and the more chances
you start taking they'll fail but the
more you start taking chances the better
you become as a comic same thing with
jujitsu
I go to Jujitsu now and I train on the
bottom and I train to control or break
his pocket that's it because by breaking
this posture then you get the openings
that's why I always say I was on uh what
my bike my white belt podcast last week
and I always said Jujitsu is an art like
stand-up comedy it keeps growing it
keeps improving and it keeps changing so
it's a living breathing [__] art
enough you can't read and research
enough of stand up the only way by
getting out there is by getting out
there it's the only problem with stand
up just like Jiu Jitsu you cannot do
stand up against a [__] mirror you
get this is me huh what happens when a
guy walks in a bar that's not going to
work with a mirror you can't do Jiu
Jitsu by yourself you got to show up and
same thing with a musician but you can
practice by yourself as a musician but
that live experience you want people in
front of you to see stage presence you
got to work on all this [__] so when
you're working on your stand-up career
guys I really
what listen Joe Rogan is an intelligent
man never been arrested never had a
problem with the law just he digs me he
doesn't dig me because I'm funny doesn't
dig me because I'm popular
me and him built a bond from working
stand up our bond is not smoking weed
like you people think or doing podcasts
are Bond
is stand up he knows the respect I have
for stand up I was a criminal all my
life I'm not a criminal when it comes to
stand up
I do everything by the book and I
[__] love it and I don't mind listen
the best thing is being down I love
being down like right now I'm down I'm
not doing theaters and I don't want to
do any of that [__] I just want to fall
in love with the simple routine of
getting on stage and having a great time
and going home that's it I don't want I
don't want to get the the most fun I had
doing stand-up was when I was broke but
anyway enough with uh
comedy in my world I got a guest today
his name is Eric roach I love this
[__] guy with all my heart uh
I met him in La like three or four years
ago and we've been friends and I've
watched this comedy career grow and it's
been a [__] pleasure for me
he's my best friend uh in the gay
community I love him to death we laugh
all the time we talk at night he tells
me stories they're coming on feet and
[__] and I love them all anyway listen
we'll be back to read the sponsors
afterward but that's it I'll see you
[__] Monday morning it's a long
podcast I don't want to take your time
have a great weekend I'll see you guys
tonight at Uncle Vinnie's if not I'll
see you all Monday morning stay black I
love you [__] enjoy Eric Rocha
we had a good time
Uncle Joey's Joy
[Music]
he does it all [__] he's like
Prince
[Music]
there he is look at him my brother I
love dressed up doing the town I'm going
to town all dressed up
I showed up with a big dick
and a bag of zero sugar Twizzlers you
understand me they make zero sugar oh my
God only at CVS [__] tremendous
you get these gay boys love this [__]
you take a little [__] with a nut
sack look at this thing you just tickle
that little nut sack
with a licorice stick as you're banging
on the muffler that go crazy these are
[__] that regular gay people don't even
understand a little licorice in the nut
sack gay guy gay guys know but these
[__] moocs at home they think they
sling dick they [__] their wives once a
month they come in two minutes gay guys
got it going on they hit each other with
feathers and Licorice and
[__] tremendous what's up you bad
[__] I miss you
I haven't [__] laughed and God knows
how long about [__] come on right dog
the reason why I had to have you on this
week I gotta complain the gay community
is slipping in New Jersey I think I got
to bring you back here and drop you off
in Asbury Park so you can [__] a bunch
of these little skinny white dudes with
tight shorts they don't know they don't
know they don't know
they don't know that you'll rip them
[__] pants off and have them sucking
that dick without two minutes right at
the baseball game with a Yankee shirt on
they're over there cheering
[__] look at Eric is stuck in motion
he looks like Lee with Edibles look at
him he's hiding behind the mic he's all
[__] stuck and [__]
Eric come back [__]
this is tremendous this is the zoom life
of podcasting oh yeah there he is all
right it got too hot the gays cut this
[__] off they don't like when you're
talking like that what's happening my
brother
I miss you man I miss you too man so
[__] long I know but guess what I'm
doing a lot better now and uh we're back
we're back [__] torturing people
beeping at people
and tell them to suck your dick
I gotta tell you so one night we were
doing uh I can't remember what we were
doing oh we were doing a mic and I
didn't have a car then and you tell me
you go all right where do you want to go
don't give me no details just tell me
where you want me to go and I said all
right I want you to take me to this gay
bar up the street and you go I've heard
of that bargained
you just looked forward and you let me
out of the bar and when I turned to tell
you thank you you [__] Cruise door
dog I don't want to get hit by sperm
like [__] uh Clarice Twining in the
[__] uh Silence of the Lamb when
she's woken up and Meg throws a shot of
[__] on you if you get hit with a college
a shot of [__] while you're walking past
the gay bar you're done that's that's
the origin of the sperm you just pass
out and wake up with birds singing
around you and [__] three gay guys
picking you up bringing it to the back
and that's it don't ever get hit with
don't let a gay guy spit on you in front
of a gay bar or [__] shoot uh come on
your leg because it's it's not gonna end
well for you any professional knows that
you told me you said you're gonna wake
up in that bar with your shoes on
backwards oh yeah
that was the ball on the other side of
Burbank Boulevard that just looked scary
oh yeah it's it's horrified because we I
took Lee there because you remember you
said you go I want you to do something
for Lee this weekend I said what's up
with you I want you to take him to that
bar
take them do them a favor I'll take him
but he's not gonna want to go let's just
do them a favor just just take him and
let him let him see how the other side
lives foreign
so when he walks in he walks in and
there's a guy in a in a leather mask
with a zipper mouth and he's blown this
dude and the other guy's got a chain on
and he's kind of delegating his rhythm
and Lee walks in the first thing he sees
that he goes I I really don't want to be
here
so wait a second the guy was sucking his
dick at the bar this is what I'm talking
about you guys go to [__] Buffalo
Wild Wings to watch UFC and eat wings
with your little [__] idiot friends
this guy walked into a bar and a guy was
getting his dick sucked with a mask with
a [__] zipper that right there that
right there I give the guy a 50 like
here you go thank you for entertainment
but the guy had a chain the [__]
control his rhythm you understand me
guys
I'm not telling you you should be gay
but I'm telling you if you're young
considerate because once you get old
like me there ain't nothing
crack-a-lackin the [__] gets old
everybody's older on you but gay guys
they sling dick till they're 80. they
don't give a [__] because there's always
some guy that's willing to suck your
dick it's it's it's unreal to me I can
be 60. I can't find somebody to suck my
dick like a girl but if I'm a man I
could just go to Asbury Park rub some
Ben Gay on my shoulders and boom there I
am [__]
laughs
I did a show in Asbury Park the other
night and that's why I had you on the
podcast before I forget as soon as I
went to Asbury Park like there were 60
people in the room maybe 10 of them were
gay guys they were very cute
but you could tell these guys don't even
go to a gym or nothing they go to a
beach and you know they don't tackle
anybody like no gay guys have ever
tackled them like they're not used to
that as I was walking back to my car I
go I like to unleash Eric on to Asbury
Park with a helicopter just drop them
off for the [__] parachute naked from
the waist down like with a [__] giant
helmet on
and just land in Asbury Park and [__]
go I'm here yum yums for a [__] week
this is some Mexican [__] coming at you
everybody likes Mexican food well here
we go
here we go
yeah the Asbury Park gay guys seem like
the gay guys in like Pueblo Colorado
like they haven't been [__] schooled
yet you know what I'm saying that these
guys don't want to go into the city
because the city's the major league of
gayism like if you go into the village
there's clubs down there that you just
coming they'll just you [__] leave
there with an IV bag filled with sperm
that goes right into your arm and [__]
right you ever see those old gay guys
they just have an IV connected to their
arm and it's like bubbly sperm and [__]
now they're giggling that it's like
ketamine for them you know what I'm
saying it's like ketamine so
sweet
don't give it to me Michael I I knew
this was gonna be [__] tough I keep
laughing in the [__] minds
I love it I love all the ships
I gotta sit around drive and think this
[__] to myself it's no fun I gotta
explain expression to people yeah yeah
it's going through my messages and I I
had one from Joey and it was like at 1
30. he tells me he goes what are you
doing [__] I just came back from
line in that chamber I'm feeling good
you know what I know I'm doing it I'm
doing it right and then he goes I was
thinking about you because they were
playing Madonna
I looked in this message was like four
minutes
is just Joey so you can get into the
group you got to move hey what
I can hear I can hear like a car honk
and I'm laughing because I realize he's
on the road and he's [__] serenading
Madonna I love it I love it a little
physical loot whatever physical
attraction when Madonna comes on you
gotta jump up and down and move your
hips Doug she's the she's the patron
saint of gay men when she shows up
everybody's getting their dick sucked
right when Madonna shows up gay people
could not be happier in their life as
soon as Madonna walks in your gay bar
gay people it's like the pope walking in
you know what I'm saying like
remember when the pope walked into a gay
bar and three guys were sitting there
good
wait to the [__] I'm serious I I got
dog I'm in New York in the 80s Madonna
walked into your gate cup everybody was
sucking dick everybody there was a
fountain of a guy sucking dick everybody
[Music]
there's a fountain of a guy
Eric one thing I am impressed with since
I left Los Angeles is a lot of you
[__] kept moving up the ladder
and I'm really proud of you guys you
Randy villarba [__] D'Agostino
there's so many years
that before the pandemic you like open
mic is you stuck it out during the
pandemic and you automatically became a
blue belt you became a [__] feature
actor at least you're getting spots at
The Improv but I'm so [__] proud of
you guys
the other day I went to uh the Yankee
game and I know you're gonna hear this
joke as soon as I say it to you how
about the Yankee game and at the end of
the row there's a beautiful black couple
she's an older woman a little heavier
you could see she was beautiful she was
beautiful you know she had white hair
but it was like dreadlocks and the
brother was [__] cool as [__] and
then there was a white couple next to
him and they were being kind of
rambunctious and the black people were
like sitting there going we don't even
give a [__] about black lives matter
what the [__] is wrong with these white
people I'm looking at them and I can see
finally the white chick puked all right
I knew I knew it was coming she just
barfs and then she gets up and they
[__] faint you know because they're
giving her Daiquiris and [__] she's
probably some little white chick from
Long Island didn't even have a [__]
burger for breakfast
so the chick fell falls down she got
like an Asian friend with her you don't
want to puke when you got an Asian
friend they don't know what the [__] to
do that they're looking around looking
for pork chops and [__]
so finally the [__] you're not gonna
believe this [__] finally the [__]
the medical crew comes down they pick
her up they do the whole thing and then
the Usher comes and he goes listen I'm
sorry about this to the two black people
the white people [__] you you puked you
out and then there was two white people
ahead of them they're like what the
[__] going on so the guy came you're
gonna love this there was three people
it was a mom a dad and a son and a black
couple behind them okay finally
the guy comes and he goes listen you got
to leave your seats because we got to
clean up the pew
and just go up there and we'll let you
know
now I heard the guy goes the black woman
goes are you gonna put us back here we
get in different seats because I don't
know let me see what I can do for you so
a couple minutes later goes by
they bring the white dude down with his
kid and he sits right on top of the puke
they cleaned it out I was 10 feet from
the Pew because I could smell it you
know that [__]
it's a lot like New Orleans you ever go
to New Orleans and while all these
people
so
the black couple comes back down and
then the nauseous like there you go
there's your chin and you ever hear that
D'Agostino joke that black people don't
Yelp only white people yell black people
[__] want to talk to the manager
right
[__] hilarious I'm looking at this
and I'm like wouldn't this be oppressive
this was a D'Agostino minute and that
black lady looked at the chair and she
looked at the white ushers he goes I
ain't sitting here I want to talk to
your [__] boss I ain't sitting this
pukey chat I want to go right down there
behind home plate that's what happens
and the dude just looked at it and she
started getting louder like listen who
do I have to call I will call George
Steinbrenner out of his grave that white
dude panicked and took her right behind
home plate they were down there jumping
up and down listening to The OJ's they
were having a good [__] time
but only in America black people don't
Yelp they get their paid there they
don't want to [__] dinner in two
months they don't want to voucher
for nothing we got to take care of this
right now that's why I love the
African-American Community they send
those pukey chairs the white people sat
down like nothing like they were like oh
great it's a great country to be and the
[__] Brothers like we ain't sitting
those puky chairs you better
and nobody sat there in the rest of the
show but the three white dudes sat there
with the kid
well so on on that note I was I was
getting the [__] monkey pox vaccine
you what yeah why oh that's right
you gotta be careful can you catch it
from slinging oh yeah oh yeah you you
can catch it's just from contact so if
if you're hugging people with monkey pox
you can get that [__] so yeah so be
careful watch out
um you're the only gay man I'm hugging
now what the [__] is monkey pox explain
it to us because a lot of white single
guys don't even want to ask like human
people
[Laughter]
so it's it's it's a a viral thing it's
like I said it's not HIV because you can
live from it so it just it gives you
really [__] terrible lesions and [__]
like that all over your [__] on your
face on your arms I got a lesion but
it's a staph infection
but if I would have known I would have
got checked out for monkey pox because I
didn't know what the [__] was going on
it took two months to heal this [__]
thing two rounds of antibiotics
well I'm I'm in line to get the vaccine
and uh they were like I'm sorry we
there's too many of you gays out here
today we don't have enough vaccine to
cover the spread and I was like oh [__]
and and just like you said though it was
this little little twinkie guy in a
[__] Tommy Bahama shirt really short
shorts he's got these big Harry Potter
glasses and he goes
um no and I'm not [__] you for 45
minutes this poor these nurses and [__]
that are just they're taking their time
they're being really really nice and the
whole time he's [__] his neck's going
back and forth and his fingers like an
inch from the guy's face and he's like
do you understand how long I had to wait
I drove from San Diego I grew up from
San Diego
and the whole time now all the gays that
everybody's just kind of like looking at
this [__] and not only that
he's standing there and he goes you know
what you know what no if you don't like
it go home and the guy [__] starts
putting the tent that had all the
vaccines away so you're putting the
[__] vaccines gays they'll [__]
they want to talk to the manager too
they don't give a [__] then they're
they're [__] they're catty about it
too like even when they do get their way
they'll still be [__] catty to a
manager now you know what the crazy
thing is like monkey pox started showing
up there's like 2 000 case in New York
yeah like I saw at the gym today it was
on CNN that's 149 in Jersey so we're
okay but
there's no wonder about this [__]
two guys got monkey pox and they already
had a vaccine my wife's like I go how
the [__] did they do it she goes well
they just used the smallpox and whatever
they get a monkey and cut his eyebrow
off and put some hairs in there I guess
that [__] does it for you right so
but here's the thing they came out with
a covert vaccine in two years white
people I'm not taking it I'm not I'm not
doing it black people I'm not doing it
Kyrie Anderson whatever people lost
their jobs and [__] this is a funny
[__] story
they put a monkey box out gay guys like
listen
I ain't dying from covert and I ain't
dying from getting [__] in the ass but
if I had to die I'm dying from covert I
ain't dying from Monkey boxes I don't
want to go out that way so I'll get the
vaccine they went right down and got the
vaccine it's funny because I went to
I went to LBI last week and when I went
for ice cream a girl walked over to me
[__] beautiful yoked and she was a
lesbian you know beautiful girl
and then she brought over like a 20
[__] Partners they were all
firefighters
in like [__] Brooklyn
and I go how many women I don't mean to
be rude I just didn't even know that
they were hiring women in the pride
Apartments because you could say it
lesbians think that you can say
she goes they hired about 60 of them and
I don't give a [__] these [__] that
didn't want the vaccine we just rolled
right the [__] up and took the vaccine
we don't need our uterus and we don't
want periods anyway so we don't give a
[__] we just want to eat [__] and fight
fires
think about that they went and got the
fact we don't give a [__] about our
uterus that's for [__] plain women
we're slinging big lips on our [__]
you know spreading bad information
[__] everybody spread bad information
you dumb [__]
well you know we had two prizes here and
it was funny we were we had we Hope
Pride and we had a Hollywood Pride
and I got to carry a sign for one of the
Prides
and they were like you want to be in the
Hollywood one too and it was so [__]
hot and it was so long that I told him I
was like I don't know if I want to do
this and I wanted to sit on the float
and I'm not [__] you Joey they
wouldn't let me on the float
wow the floats were for the [__]
Go-Go boys and the strippers
they had all the ugly facts doing the
legwork well you gotta show up with the
[__] thumb see me I'm a [__] I'm no
good looking [__] but I'm showing up with
a song chunkletas and I'm getting right
up there with the Spanish people because
the Spanish people will take anybody as
long as you're up there slinging
[Music]
they're up there yelling throwing sperm
at the people with confetti they don't
[__] around the Latino gay contingent I
love them they're the ones that Loop
sucked me in because they don't give a
[__] all the other gays and races talk
too much Latinos they don't care right
gay Races they always I'm thinking of
being even like when a brother's gay
shut the [__] up you're gay I'm happy
but don't [__] break it down like a
white dude like the reason why I'm gay
is because I was playing basketball one
time and some guy slammed on me no he
didn't yeah Uncle [__] with you and this
is what happens crazy cracky
[__] you probably had one of
these black pedophiles like African
mambata as an uncle or some [__] do you
see they're trying to take Africa
bambaata down because he molested little
boys like 80 years ago they're still
like [__] don't listen to Planet Rock
rock rock Planet Rock don't stop rock
rock Planet Rock
I was pissed because they didn't even
talk to gay people in the New York uh
gay parade the pride parade they didn't
have gay men it was a transvestite a
[__] [__] uh
uh whatever the [__] you called not a
transvestite a transgender [__]
whatever a guy was in charge of the way
he was the [__] minute gay is gay
pride and also they just chiseled the
people let me tell you what the [__]
did this is why I'm really mad at the
transgenders and gay people will
understand what I'm talking about
because just with that little [__]
they don't cut off their dicks they
don't do nothing and they want to take
all the [__] heat from gay men
lesbians and most importantly
[__] just regular [__] the
people who introduced me to life let me
tell you something
these guys they laid the brickwork for
all this that's going on in this country
really think about it like the old gay
guys I saw it one of my best friends and
I loved to death until I robbed him he
was part of that gay [__] he he set
the groundwork for the gay people and
the second people that did it were the
transvestite the guys that work hard as
a butcher all week and then Friday comes
they want to stop they want to duct tape
that nut sack and that dick put on a wig
shave that goatee and just let the
pieces fall where they make you know
what I'm saying those guys show up at
like the bottom of the bag of the gay
community they'll show up like a gay guy
missing a leg like he got shot in
Vietnam or something like that
they never show up on like healthy
looking gay guys that's okay
but they've thrown him they've
eliminated that whole transvestite thing
that pissed me off
there's still a place in my heart for
[__] just people guys that just
don't want to make the full commitment
they want to be Henry again on Monday
you know what I'm saying like they want
to be whatever their names are Adam
Henry I don't [__] them
I think the funniest gay thing I've ever
heard was that gay dude that told me
about Adam and Steve I almost [__]
died he's like listen I talked to you
about Adam and Steve I'm like who's Adam
and Steve because it used to be Adam and
Eve but now it's Adam and Steve
you might used to crack me up because
you uh you talk about ramrod you said
that the floors were designated to each
branch of the of the pride community and
you said the first floor was the gay
floor second was lesbian he said third
floor is where you just do whatever you
have to do
listen don't let me miss it
I'm gonna buy you a drink so I don't
miss that
listen gay people love that song there's
another one called
it's by some Puerto Rican guys
it's the sexo let's something okay
it's not dancing dancing it's always on
Studio 54. it's an old game song from
the 70s it is brilliant because at the
end the Puerto Rican guy goes
okay okay darling my chiffon is wet my
wig is wet he says when he says his
chiffon is wet I almost crashed the car
every [__] time and I've heard that
song since I was six
but every time he goes my chiffon is wet
darling my chiffon is what
[Laughter]
top because that's where you would get
the best Coke and what always what
always made me laugh when she said when
the cops came in to raid the place that
black guy always had he like he said he
was on skates and he had a whistle a
little whistle I was the lookout and he
would beep beep
that's the cops [__] sucker little
whistle
it's like the beginning of Donna Summer
Bad Girls
when you hear that whistle you know
they're [__] putting on that gear
they got their [__] black things
under their eyes they're gonna go on the
sunlight and be [__] getting tackled
people
that's why he said he said it was you
that's why I like him because they're
smart they're smart
dog we used to
we used to a ton in L.A like with Lee me
and you at night we would just do guys
we didn't need to go to a bar we didn't
need to hang out with famous Comics we
didn't need to do [__]
we would just get high we would talk
about being gay and Lee
that was it that was it I don't know if
I told the story just because it's it's
[__] in the lore now but you had called
me and you had said hey Lee Lee's coming
right now tell him he doesn't look good
and I was like all right why what's
going he goes no just [__] tell me it
doesn't look good he's fine okay all
right love you bye
and Lee comes around the corner and I
look at him and he's like hey what's
going on and I go hey are you feeling
all right man
and he goes why and I go I you look kind
of Pale
and dude he went he goes [__] God
damn it did Joey talk to you and I go no
why what's up what's wrong and he goes
oh all right so I went to a rub and tug
and I think the lady gave me some
what
what they offered to finish me off and I
was like okay yeah so then I [__] go
talk to Joey and then Joey starts
talking he's like oh you can't go to
that place you didn't hear they had an
outbreak of an STD you got to go get
yourself checked you don't look good and
I had to bite my [__] lip because
then I understood why you were like when
you see Lee telling me to look good
like in you Lee didn't even do the mic
he goes I gotta go
get the card peeled up
I made a big mistake
I made a big [__] mistake and we all
make huge mistakes you know Josh Wolf
put up some videos of me with his son
from 20 years ago and I go Josh you know
we weren't thinking clearly
that should have been a web series you
know oh I love doing a podcast with Lee
I enjoyed that office I enjoyed
everything about it but my biggest
mistake was that office was not taping
people from the minute they walked in
which I don't like doing because it's
creepy I have to tell you and once I
tell Michael I tell you that the
camera's on you're gonna act differently
and that's what we didn't want but I
gotta be honest with you some of those
nights
before and after I wish people could see
those
they will [__] you know you gotta
remember we would end the podcast at 10
but we wouldn't leave that till one in
the morning
one two in the [__] morning you know
we did a podcast at one in the afternoon
we didn't get home till six
it was like a two-hour podcast a one
hour pre-party and a two hour after
party we get food and [__] you know
and people could never understand but
for me I think one of the best
experiences I had on that podcast was
one night
he goes to Vegas this was the story he
goes to Vegas with my other buddy and my
other body loves to torture people he
was completion and not going to Vegas
with that [__] he gave Leah
Vicodin or something a happy pill
Lee had a couple drinks and then Lee was
he lost all whatever you know it happens
to all of us I used to have a cocktail
want to break into a house I would lose
control you know so
they went to this [__] strip club not
a strip club a tug and jug or whatever
and there was one Chinese chick left
and I guess she rubbed them both like
she was going from one room to the other
so when he called me to do it he goes
don't say nothing
I took lead to get a hand job he [__]
loved it he paid 140 or whatever I
actually didn't say nothing until he for
about six weeks I didn't bring anything
up I was gonna set him up it was one of
the greatest setups I've ever done in my
life I really wanted to attack him like
a week later but I had to bite my tongue
on my left this guy let it [__]
romulate whatever that word is so one
night
something I just walked in like Lee have
you spoken to him and he goes no not at
all
I'm like that's funny and then after was
when I go leave you haven't spoken to
him and he goes no not really oh listen
I don't want to [__] hurt your
feelings
did you go to some massage parlor with
him and he just his eyes got big and he
turned pale he didn't think I knew
yeah it was fun
I go fun
I go Larry's in the hospital his dick
blew up now I kept the straight face it
was one in the morning it was one in the
morning we're [__] higher than [__]
and he just looked at me and froze he's
like what are you talking about your dog
his dick blew up
and he's not in good shape he's in the
hospital in critical condition I go the
chick had some [__] hand and
when she rubbed his dick I go did you
get a [__] from the same girl and
he's like and he was just damn by this
time all the color in his face had gone
his little lip was trembling
and he goes yeah I I think I did I go
well then you better get checked out and
he's like he started making Jew noises
the little noises he used to make
what am I gonna tell Paul you're not
gonna tell Paula nothing
but the bat like I'm playing him and
he's digging himself deeper he doesn't
stop and go you [__] he's
digging himself deeper on his own like
he's like
and finally just to take the attention
out of the room I go Lee why don't you
go in the other room
bring a light with you bring the
magnifying glass look at your dick we
had a magnifying glass and think I go
look at your dick and see what's going
on see if there's a there's a couple
spots then we'll go to a doctor tomorrow
he takes about 10 minutes he comes back
and he's like
I have a spot on my dick and I'm like oh
no wow
I'm just feeding them he's online
looking for doctors it's one thing The
Mortals
should I go to the hospital no they
don't have stuff to kill that type of
syphilis I just kept giving it Lanes
and he's starting to [__] I mean he
was [__] upset I'm like oh lee I'm
only [__] with you he's like huh and
then he gave out one more Junior
and I'm like Lee nothing to happen
that next morning I called him even
after I told him the truth
I go where are you he goes can I call
you back I go why why because I'm at the
doctor's office getting attached
he was always at the doctor's office
always
you know what's funny though and I'll
give him credit to this every once in a
great while he would try to [__] with
you too and it would crack me up when we
were going I don't remember where the
[__] we were going but we were driving
back and you got pulled over
oh [__] up in Ventura or something like
that and and we're sitting there and I'm
in the back of the car and you said you
knew there you go all right everybody
hands up and you put your hands up on
the dashboard and he said just make sure
your hands are where they can see him
and they go I'm not being no statistic
cute
oh we're in the car laughing you go God
damn it you go
you could have been I should have been
looking out I should have been looking
out
and you were upset and then Lee just
looks at you and he goes do you think
you're gonna get a ticket
and it was it was the equivalent in
Animal House when he goes over to those
guys and he just goes you guys playing
cards
foreign
how the [__] do I know if he's gonna
give me
I hope he doesn't and he did he just
told the slow fat I think I was doing
like 90 or 80. you were [__] I was
all of that stuff because what you would
do on the way up because we were driving
and you were listening to disco and
there were these cones and you would
swerve and you would hit a cone
[__] it
though people have no idea I love to hit
cones run over cones and I do this [__]
but I'm by myself to entertain myself I
don't need nobody in the car with me to
have a good time that's why I was like
because the ride up was just as much
[__] fun I was like and I was like I
was calculated I was like that it's like
a [__] like a couple hundred a cone
that you hit and just as many cones as
you hit like we wouldn't have [__]
made money off the game
dog I'm thinking about those people
around the corner from my house I used
to run over that cones every night
what they think is happening right now
like they're probably at Barbecue's like
man whoever was running over our cones
just stop running over dog I can be it
could be one of the morning I could be
tired and I go I gotta go back over
there and run over that cones I could
have to take a [__] and I would run over
there to run over that cones
we we would do gigs like at fourth wall
we'd do gigs of fourth well and I know
you did this on purpose you would time
it so that by the time we got out a
fourth wall to go get something to eat
the Knights of Columbus would come out
of their meetings
for all the window
that he would [__] deal I gotta be
honest you wanna I love to laugh I love
to laugh I love to laugh at stupid [__]
I love when you're high on an edible or
high on a mushroom and you laugh and you
can't control yourself from it like you
think you're gonna die I love all that
[__] but
I had a friend growing up he's passed
now
I love them to that it's crazy died
about a year and a half ago and then
I've been thinking about him a lot the
last year because I couldn't I was too
[__] sick to even know what the [__]
was going on when he died he was
king of that
when I tell you
there's times I drive and I hear his
voice and I laugh because I know what he
would say about some of these people
like where I got like I was telling Mike
that I went to the yank game there was a
lady on her feet were purple like she
had diabetic feet and [__] like I got a
[__] fungi toenail I'm all right but
my feet ain't [__] purple or turning
red or pink this lady was [__] huge
her feet were purple on the bottom she
had dirt on the heels she was a mess
you know and both feet were purple like
she had like blood clots or whatever on
the foot what was her answer she's
eating popcorn at the Yankee game and
all of a sudden she just put two tattoos
on her foot like this will take care of
the feet
nobody's gonna know about the diabetes
I don't even know how we got to this but
I love driving and just saying like the
most important funniest thing is when
you see somebody
and they look a little off and you say
to yourself what the [__] is this thing
look at this [__] Beauty the best is
when you're with somebody and you see
somebody that looks [__] up and you
hit them in the arm and you go relative
and they just look at you like what the
[__] that's not my cousin but that's the
best whenever I see somebody [__] up
I'll look at wherever I'm with and I go
hey relatives
but I used to have a buddy that would go
up to you and just say [__] like there
was a guy once freezing at the bus stop
and he pulled up next to me he's like
get home [__] look at you you're
free there was another guy picking up
paper with his stick once and he asked
him how's business picking up the guy
was Furious another guy was swapping you
know sweeping the stairs at six in the
morning we'd be all coked up for the
night before my friend would pull up get
in the house [__] and the guy will
pick up the broom it's cool to hit us
and we peel off and [__]
I remember one time I was on a bus on
Bergenline Avenue and there was a dude
next to me the window was open there was
a dude next to me with the window open
and I swear to God I spit and it landed
right on his [__] head right here
like a little head like a little
loop-dee-doo like a little dippity-doop
with a curl and he's kind of just
shaking his head and the spit kept going
back and forth like one of those little
Chinese drums they use and acupuncture
with a little drum with the little two
[__] arms
unreal unfucking real that laughing is
still funny as [__] I I because I I
still remember this you would pull [__]
and it's like one of my favorite
memories you would [__] and me and
Lee would just sit there and Leah had
the perfect analogy for you it was it
was the best one I've ever heard
we were sitting there one time because
you had left and you would tell me you
go I'm I'm sorry and you were
legitimately like apologetic and I go
what's what man what's going on and I
thought something was wrong with you and
you go
I took all kinds of garlic pills today
to fart and really fresh in the room up
for you
I can't fart I don't know what's wrong
with me
and you walked out and me and Lee were
sitting there and I go
why does he think I would like that
oh my mother just started laughing and
he looks at me and he goes
the thing about Joey
is he has a plan
but he's the only one that knows what it
is
and I looked and I was like oh my God
that's exactly what it is and that's
you've always been like a practical
joker like that and all the like even
all the gigs that you've done it was so
[__] funny because we did the Ice
House one time and we pulled up and I
remember you would hot box that car and
I mean just weed smoke is billowing in
it and then Lee would just sit there and
I remember looking because the show
started at eight and it's it's like 750
752 755
and finally at like 7 56 Lee looks at
you and he goes we we should probably go
in because the show starts at 8. and you
took a big old rip and you go well I'm
not on till nine you're on at eight
[Laughter]
door oh my God oh my God
ran around the car
and then I was I was [__] laughing
and we were laughing when we got out
please like [__] waddling around the
car and he goes I don't know why you're
[__] laughing because you're coming
up right after me you [__]
laughs you know man it was really crazy
that those were the best comedy gigs I
was doing at the time
really yeah because I was doing all
those theaters and [__] and that wasn't
comedy that was a [__] hell hole like
I wasn't having any fun doing those
beaters you're supposed to be having fun
doing those theaters I wasn't had become
work to me my gigs with you guys
were the gigs I enjoyed those little
simple gigs that nobody gives a [__]
that we could Giggle and fart and you
know that's what comedy is man and
the last two three four five six years
that comedy gift had been taken away
from me it was work it wasn't fun no
more me going to the ice house with you
guys that was fun me going to The Comedy
Store with you guys that way and even
The Comedy Store
became work I had to work I had to be a
comic I couldn't just be me at the ice
house I don't give a [__]
I was going up there to hang out with
you guys to talk to people it was 98
people
you know it was a great room it was wild
though because you would do sets and we
would we would watch you because truth
is is not every feature watches their
headliner and they should but we would
watch you because you would you would do
[__] that we had never you had talked
about it in the car and you were like I
think I'm gonna put this together and
you would do it and it'd be [__]
solid on stage and then we do another
gig and you do it completely different
and that would be solid too and I just
remember it was such a it's such an odd
thing that you would fly that way like
it was
it was just one of those things where a
small group of people where you could
really let loose and like really look at
people yeah you were it was incredible
it really was it was something to see
because I still have notes that Lee and
I we would write down like [__] that you
said and how you phrased it and we would
say like [__] dude he did it this way
this night but the punch was harder this
night and it was so wild because you're
set up versus your premise you would
find different [__] you would go down
different Avenues I mean you said
something to me one time that every
comic you're in amalgam of the friends
that you keep
and it's it's [__] true because now
like I said when when I go on stage it
it there's a little Joey Diaz in there
there's a little bit of Eddie Murphy in
there there's a little bit of Richard
Pryor I mean all of these Comics that I
adored they're all in there and then as
you start to kind of progress I think
that's how like The Improv started
coming is honestly I just I I stopped
giving a [__] and it was like I want to
have fun because that's that's what I'm
about this for is it's the fun so yeah
and that that was it like you would you
your green room was always something
fascinating because I've had Comics ask
me what you're like in the green room
and I always laugh because I was liking
it to [__] a fighter right before a
fight
because you weren't all jump around and
expended you were like okay I want to
sit down and it's the Calm before the
storm
and I remember we were doing shows in La
Jolla and you beat the [__] out of that
first show you beat the [__] out of it
and then you came back to that room and
you told me and Lee you said all right
change it up change up everything and we
were like what do you mean you go we
have people that were from the first
show they're Stanford the second show
again and they they released some more
seeds so whatever you're doing just [__]
around with it this is the crowd to do
it you've got a bit that you want to
work on do it now
and you did that and you did it
completely different than how you did
the first show and it was one of the
craziest [__] things and that night
is really how I figured out okay there's
a difference between being in the moment
and having all this written [__]
prepared because you knew the material
because you'd gone over it so much but
you couldn't really live in it if you
weren't being like that because you did
something that nobody nobody believes me
when I tell them this you would never
tell us how much time we were doing
we would always have to hear off other
people and I tell other Comics that they
go well how the [__] would you know when
to come off stage and I'd say well you'd
get the light you'd get the light of
five
and it goes through Joey wouldn't tell
you I go no anytime I tried it once and
you looked at me and you go what's with
all the questions
and I just went uh
don't don't ask him don't ask him how
much time and I go it's not something we
kind of need to know
and he went I don't know just [__]
ran away but you would never tell us the
time so what that forced me to do was if
I had a bit I had to get I had to
explore it I had to live in it I had to
try it out I had to really [__] go
back and forth now it's it's hilarious
because I'll go up there and I'll I did
a show just recently with Jeff dye and
Kurt Metzger it was uh the Hard Lemonade
show and Monterey is a great great great
comic she's coming up you'll you'll hear
about her she's like hey I want you to
do this show I was like okay cool I
don't even know if they gave me how much
time I was doing
and they asked me they go don't you
don't you know how much time you're
doing I was like no why
and they were like I I because so you
can do your you say you know what
material to do
and I was like I yeah I don't know I
just I don't work that way
and it's from you that I got that and
like I said I I love I love doing that
dude is that you you learn how to be a
Savage on stage by putting yourself
through that kind of [__] and so you
would never do that but it's funny
because I've never got to tell you this
to thank you for that it it put me in a
different a different category of Comedy
now because the one thing that I really
love about that I had drinks with Jeff
dying we were talking about you last
night
same thing with the Brian Simpson too
everybody talks about you and how hard
you crush and I get because you would
you would say like me when there's five
minutes left
and I was like [__] like how much time
is he gonna do though how much because
you would always [__] play with the
premise and you would play with how you
were gonna do the punch
and I mean it was it was amazing to
watch so it was it was like going to
school but in the best way because there
was a night where I just I wasn't I
wasn't figuring it out and you told me
why don't you come to the store and you
said you need to watch some good Comics
because you've been watching too much
open mic comedy
and it you were right and I was like
[__] I'm getting bad habits from
watching this [__] I gotta watch how
it's done well
and then yeah and then it the game
changed but it's just it's wild and
you're gonna hate this but I've been
doing one time I [__] I did so good
at the show and you were there and you
would tell me I want you to I want you
to stop
not doing gay [__] I want you to open
with your gay [__] and I was like I
don't know man I don't know if you go I
don't want to hear that
open with the gay [__] and I was like
all right fine
and I did I go is anybody gay here
and nobody [__] raised their hands
I'm like okay I go does anybody think
somebody's a [__] here
and everybody started laughing but you
were behind that audience and you never
did this you were behind that audience
and you were like it was like you were
Shadow boxy you were like yeah yeah and
then you [__] went back to the green
room and I was laughing because you
would you would lean forward and you
would [__] laugh and that was it for
me that was my like I said I Club wise I
I want to be in at clubs I want to do
all that [__] but for me that was what
made me
legitimate was when you leaned forward
and you were [__] their Shadow Boxing
my set with me against all these [__]
straight people and it was great I got
like followers from that I have people
that still talk about that show and that
was because you had said no you need to
be who you are that's it that's it and
yeah it was it was a [__] you know
comedy could be really hard
or it could be really easy I love comedy
I know how to get good at it and it's
all I know I don't know how to fix a car
I can't make chicken cutlets I don't
know anything but I know comedy I know
how to get funny and I know the state of
mind that you have to have I've been
talking a lot on patreon lately about
the little adjustments to be that much
better of a person
it's just little adjustments people
think you need all the it's just little
adjustments it all goes back to Jujitsu
the details there's little details and
if you stick to those details everything
will work out for you
and I tell you getting on stage I think
that being an immigrant
I don't know I don't know if it's being
Cuban I don't know but I can't anything
we do is a privilege in this country
anything we do is a privilege
we take spots for granted sometimes when
I started in comedy there was no spots
I did 13 spots a month that's all that
was available to me I did them all
I needed to do more I needed to do 16
and 18 and 20. so you know you keep what
my point is that every spot that you do
whether it's at the [__]
and an open mic or at a theater with 2
000 people
you're always trying something new
I don't care
subconsciously you gotta try something
new subconsciously you have to grow as a
human being whether you're on stage Jiu
Jitsu or guitar player ACL a CEO you got
to grow so you got to keep doing things
every day to keep you fresh as a human
being my daughter Goes to Camp after
three weeks I ask do you still like Camp
She Gazette
we have to keep things [__] so for me
to keep things normal I gotta switch
things up I don't want to [__] be
married to a set as a comic
your third to fifth year in comedy I
want you to be married to your set
because I want you to have a beginning
and middle and ending a song has a
beginning man everything has a beginning
so I don't want you to go up third to
five to seven year Comics I want you to
stay in your thing but note that by the
time you hit six years you're gonna have
your set just to reel you in if things
go [__] nuts but I want you to go out
there and try different things and you
know there's a white there's a BJJ white
belt page on Instagram and they're
[__] great I did that podcast last
week because they everybody gives you a
10 page [__] thing to make you better
and comedy it's only two lines I gotta
tell you do this switch this
you know adjust this but they make it
when you read their what the inspiration
they give you every day they tell you
that If You're Gonna Roll today in Jiu
Jitsu which for us is getting on stage
try something new put yourself
in a horrible position
so you learn how to get yourself out of
those positions there's no secret
why a man by the name of Joe Rogan is a
great comic and he ended up becoming a
great comic because to all his advice to
all the people that advised him they
told him not to let me open for him
Joe Rogan said I'm a stand-up I'm gonna
follow him till I get it right
wow and then something changed when I
got to the store in 2016. I had to start
following Joe Rogan
and how do you think that felt for me oh
geez I had to learn how to follow delete
I had to learn how to follow all those
guys so comedy you're always [__]
learning guys and every time you go on
stage
it's to learn something it's not just I
don't give a [__] of this three people
in the audience
good that gives me time to do a [__]
uh what's the thing Belushi used to do
the somersault cartwheels do a [__]
cartwheel for four people I don't give a
[__]
but you you said this one time it was
talking about poisonous sugar-free I
don't want people saying Joy you're
gonna be a fat [__] diabetes you're
gonna get a foot like that lady that's
how red her foot was and she got a
tattoo in the middle of it zero free CBS
and don't forget to join CVS Health pass
they give you tremendous discounts every
month if you're into condoms and [__]
perfume for [__] and monkey pop now
can you get a monkey pox if you wear a
condom this [__] eats through the
comments
lambskin
those monkeys ain't [__] around
our monkey pox they ain't [__] around
you you said this one time and it's
funny because my buddy's the the rosie
triplets they always remembered this too
you said on stage you go look if your
jokes ain't working then you go to your
stories if your stories ain't working
then you go to crowd work and if crowd
work ain't working you better dance
[__]
you better dance I did it for years when
things got [__] up you know I was
telling somebody that day and we'll
leave on this
because there's a lot of young Comics
I'm gonna watch this
I'm going to tell you this because this
question
keeps repeating itself to me and to
other people
should your comedy change during this
walk period
not at all if you change it you failed
if you change the comedy for people and
people's feelings you failed
what was I going to say
the monkey pox eats through condoms no
no no no you failed but I tell you what
I found out last week this is why I want
to talk to Eric because I made a comedy
breakthrough last week that I've known
about for years right now they're
telling you not to do this not to say
this not to say this let me tell you
what I realized last week
there's two groups of people that love
to get involved in your comedy and tell
me I'm wrong Eric and I'll tell you who
I saw do it who taught me it and it
changed my life as a group of men
there's groups whatever
African-Americans Chinese Filipinos but
there's two groups that love when you
involve them in your act and you can say
anything you want to just don't be dirty
don't talk about ass [__] all the
[__] that me and my man talk about here
and that's gay men
gay men are the most receptive groups
and if you go to a do a gay joke if
you're going to do a comedy show and
there's a table of 10 gay guys don't
even worry about material you don't need
it just talk to them
just talk to them and they're gonna
[__] love you they're gonna take you
out to dinner afterwards they're
probably gonna try to [__] you just turn
them down but I want you to learn this
and the second group of people who love
to be involved in your comedy routine is
African Americans just don't be an
[__] and call to insult them but you
could say anything call them Tarzan you
know the sisters look like TLC whatever
I I I started comedy with African
Americans I said anything but the
disgusting word and they went along with
it you could say anything you want I'd
eat black [__] it keeps my teeth clean
the [__] hair I used to say all that
[__] and not once an African-American
woman come up to me and go I thought
that was nasty not once in fact they
said you're nasty cause you eat that
[__] nasty [__] you know sisters
are the best so I'm sick and tired young
comics of people telling you your
[__] job do your job and if you do it
correctly and if you stand your ground
they'll accept you no matter what you
say to them as long as you don't call
them [__] [__] or you know HIV
people don't you don't need to say that
have a great time
gay people
by people they all want to have a
[__] gay a great gay time a great
time
you know nobody wants to [__]
again you know because listen if you say
the same thing to 100 women
if I get 100 women to stand on my line
go listen that blouse is beautiful 99
are gonna enjoy it one of them is going
to say I felt like that sentence was a
little sexual and
kind of you know it kind of scared me
that's it so with lesbian women with
women you got to be a little bit more
careful but speak to them tell them
where you're at tell them five that's
what stand up is is the truth
why the [__] are we going away from the
truth that lying to us nobody's woke
you're as woke as you want to be get on
stage and [__] tell them to suck your
dick nobody will be woke no more
think about if you tell somebody woke to
suck your dick and look him in the eye
they'll go okay I got a lot I gotta stop
doing this [__] where are you performing
at listen Leo be here and not this week
next week we're gonna call you again and
do another three-way [__] zoom on
Comedy 101 for the next week for these
[__] people at home that want to
learn how to do comedy and have a
[__] you know everybody's got a
[__] uh you know what do you do with
woke now how do you do your comedy just
go up there and be the dirty as you can
if you come up to me and go then walk
I'm gonna go then go up there and open
up with the [__] you pulling the
Arabs head [__] him in the ass
putting a sock in his mouth let them sit
there and go what the [__] is he saying
yeah you know what what you did in the
coffee really quick is you said wow guys
I was with a buddy in the car and we
were listening to you and you go well
guys
Betty White's dead and I don't feel too
good myself either [__] no Betty White
is that that [__] finally died she
kicked the buckler let's wait for her to
be 100 for what so so a [__] could get
drier after 70. your quad is just dry as
[__] you're walking around squeaking
half of these 80 year old women don't
even want to be alive
I love you Eric where are you going to
be performed in the next couple weeks
all right buddy so I'm gonna be in Vegas
on the 12th
um you can check my website Eric
roachcomedy.com also my YouTube channel
and then I'm gonna be in San Diego at
the mad house on the 14th August 14th so
yeah we're we're making moves buddy I
miss you you look great I miss you too
man and like I said I'm doing these
shows so I guess you're going to be
doing it in November or December so
whichever one I'm there buddy I love you
with all my heart brother all right and
I'm happy you did this today because
I do this for me I don't give a [__]
about the guests I do this for me so I
get a good laugh I need to have some
[__] gay humor in my life next time
we'll talk about gay pride and how many
people's feet you came on and [__] rub
[__] coming there I would love to be
[__] good and then come on your hand
and rubbed it in the [__] eye wanna
and they're coming like I'm coming yeah
yeah I too [__]
I love you and now for a word for my
[__] sponsors Jack hit it
all right I want to thank you guys and I
want to thank Eric Rocha for making me
[__] laugh my ass off today but I
also want to thank facta facta is ready
to eat meal delivery service listen
they're tremendous it's summertime you
ain't got time to go home and cook and
chop with facta quick lunch or a fully
prepared dinner it's just two minutes
away
in fact this new Protein Plus preference
makes easy to power up with delicious
meals and at least 30 grams of protein
per serving you're not going to get
there anywhere else these Chef crafted
recipes are packed with restaurant
quality flavor stop spending your
precious hours at the store online
cooking it's too hot for that let facta
deliver some pre-prepared meals to your
house they're gonna blow you away they
got vegan veggie Protein Plus keto
calorie smart option energy bites veggie
sides and more but there's smoothies and
cold pressed juices are tremendous
tremendous so head on over to go dot
factor75.com slash Joey 130 that's go
that factor
75.com Joey 130 use code joey130 to get
130 off
six boxes of food that's code Joey 130
at Gold Dot factor75.com slash Joey 130
for 130 off the joint is also brought to
you by
Bluetooth listen if you're thinking of
slinging dick and you wanted to call
again you want to wet that whistle blue
shoe has got you covered what is
Bluetooth Joey they're an online service
that delivers the same ingredients as
Cialis and Viagra and a chewable tablet
oh at a fraction of the cost take them
many times
and be ready whenever the opportunity
arises let me tell you something blue
true is great you put a little package
in your pocket and when you're ready to
go there you are everybody's happy you
can pull your own hair out of your head
the process is a simple stock sign up at
bluetooth.com once you're approved
you'll receive your prescription within
days you're gonna talk to a medical
license provider first but the best part
is it's all done online no this no
doctor's office no awkward conversation
Bluetooth tablets are made in the USF in
the USA and shipped in a discreet
package nobody will know not even you
until you open it that's how good
Bluetooth is but listen all jokes aside
you want to wet your whistle it's the
summer time it's the best time to do it
you can sling dick with confidence have
blue shoes so go to bluetooth.com and to
code Joey and get the first month free
did you hear what I'm saying free so
your August you'll be slinging dick on
Uncle Joey go to bluetooth.com and get
the party started I want to thank
Bluetooth for sponsoring the podcast
also CBD lion when it comes to CBD
they're the best how do I know I've been
working with them for four years I put
on everything I'm getting old guys CBD
line will help you with anxiety pain
it's just great whether you have uh
arthritis I had some arthritis on my
wrist that was bothering me I put some
of the cream on for four or five days
pain is gone that's CBD lion so do me a
favor read the third party lab results
if there's anything you see Preston
coach Joey join a church and get 20 your
first order at cbdlion.com the best you
bad [__] I want to thank CBD
lion I want to thank Bluetooth I want to
thank
[__] DraftKings I want to thank
everybody who else came on this week
factor I love you is all CBD lion have a
great week we'll be back Monday tip top
Magoo ready to go I love you
[__]
[Music]
you know